Democrats seal the deal with socialist
Bernie Sanders in Nevada
Bernie embraces actual communists again
and the underlings fight it out for
second place i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show the venture Pierrot
show is sponsored by expressvpn why
haven't you gotten a VPN yet visit
expressvpn dot-com slash Ben all righty
so the Democrats married the hooker in
Vegas they made the move you know they
say that what happens in Vegas stays in
Vegas but that doesn't hold true if you
go to Vegas you go find a hooker you
hook up with her overnight and then you
decide to run down to the nearest
wedding chapel find Elvis tomb area and
now you're stuck with that the rest of
your life well well done Democrats
that's exactly what you did over the
weekend the Nevada caucuses cut in favor
of the open communists Bernie Sanders I
wanna say he's an open communist I mean
that he's an open communist I mean the
guy has yet to meet a communist regime
he will not praise he tends to pretend
that he's all about Denmark and Norway
without actually knowing the first thing
about Denmark or Norway it really is
astonishing how he's been able to get
away with this he'll say that he wants a
health care system like Denmark's and
then his health care system has nothing
to do with Denmark Denmark does not look
like Medicare for all but in any case
Bernie Sanders walks away from Nevada
with a massive that victory he ends up
with 46 points 8 percent of the vote in
Saturday's Nevada caucuses Joe Biden
coming in at 20.4% Biden is trying to
claim this as some sort of victory
because after all worked about to head
on to South Carolina which is Joe
Biden's last skin it's the Alamo for Joe
Biden Biden has a shot there he's about
a 50/50 shot to win South Carolina if
Biden were to win South Carolina that
does complicate the picture because then
all of a sudden it looks like Joe Biden
is not completely dead in the water if
Bernie wins South Carolina the sucker is
over before it begins Pete Budaj edge
walks to a thirteen point nine percent
of the vote Elizabeth Warren despite her
supposedly glorious showing in that
debate last week that complete crap show
debate Reservoir Dogs style ending of
the debate last week Elizabeth Warren
only got nine point eight percent of the
vote in the Nevada Democratic caucuses
Tom Styer at four point six percent and
Amy Klobuchar at four point two percent
that means that Bernie runs away with
this thing more than doubling up his
nearest competitor Joe Biden and Bernie
was super excited about it
he was triumphant about it in fact
here's what Bernie had to say being
triumphant speaking in front of a rally
full of filled with hysterical
socialists this is clip two we are going
to win across the country because the
American people are sick and tired of a
president who lies all of the time they
are sick and tired of a corrupt
administration they want an
administration which is based on the
principles of justice economic justice
social justice racial justice okay so
this old communist is going to be your
leader going into the clubhouse Bernie
Sanders is campaigning also like Donald
Trump did in 2016 against the so-called
Democratic establishment what's weird
about this is that by and large at the
polls show is that Democrats like
members of the base are much happier
with their own party than Republicans
were back in 2016 back in 2016
Republicans were deeply unhappy with
their own Democratic Party establishment
Democrats by and large are pretty happy
with the Democratic establishment
because the Democratic establishment has
bent over backwards to make room for the
Bernie Sanders and the Ilhan omar's and
the Rashida to leaves and the AOC s
they've done magazine covers Nancy
Pelosi astana zine covers with these
people so it's very weird for Bernie to
run against the so-called establishment
he tweeted out I've got some moves for
the Republican establishment I've got
news for the Democratic establishment
they can't stop us well here is the
problem they sort of can and what i mean
by that is not that the Democratic
establishment is gonna stop burning I
think Bernie has basically a clear glide
path to the nomination at this point I'm
very doubtful that Joe Biden is able to
pick up to South Carolina even if he
does it seems to me that Bernie has a
road to the plurality of the delegates
simply because Michael Bloomberg and Joe
Biden would then split the vote so it
actually doesn't clarify the picture if
Biden wins in South Carolina Biden wins
in South Carolina Bloomberg is still
spending all this money for Super
Tuesday and suddenly instead of there
being one moderate in the lane because
Biden drops out presumably instead you
have two moderates in that lane
splitting the vote and then Bernie
running right up that left side and
picking up his thirty percent of the
vote and winning across the board in a
lot of these primaries it's really not
about that the problem for Bernie
Sanders that the numbers just don't add
up when it comes to his national
poll standing which of course is why
President Trump was congratulating crazy
Bernie it's very obvious that president
Trump would love to see Bernie Sanders
as the nominee he certainly loves the
cast he's seeing inside the Democratic
Party he tweeted out in the aftermath of
the Nevada results Knicks like crazy
Bernie is doing Grell he's doing well in
the great state of Nevada Biden and the
rest look wick and nowhere mini Mike can
restart his campaign after the worst
debate performance in the history of
presidential debates
congratulations Bernie and don't let
them take it away from you
so Trump is just itching itching to dump
a billion dollars in ads in the swing
state sunburn and he should be because
as we will see Bernie provides rich
fodder for attack but that said be
careful of what you wish for the
monkey's paw applies in politics
whatever you wish for very often it
comes true and then it comes back to
bite you directly on the ass as Hillary
Clinton learn what you wish for Donald
Trump and then got the full Trump in
2016 we'll get back to this in just one
second first let's talk about safety and
security so I am deeply worried
constantly about safety and security
unfortunately I tend to get a lot of
deference but more than that my
neighborhood is becoming less safe
because hell I live in Los Angeles and
they've decided that the best thing to
do would be to hand over the
neighborhood to people who are
committing petty crimes we've seen
fairly dramatic rise in my neighborhood
in Breaking and Entering well one of the
ways that people break and enter is they
bring the doorbell they make sure you're
not home and then they proceed to break
in your house one way you can prevent
this is by having ring devices on your
home rings mission is to make a
neighborhood safer you already know
about their smart video doorbells and
cameras that protect millions of people
everywhere ring helps you stay connected
it's your home anywhere in the world so
if there's a package delivery or a
surprise visitor you get an alert and
you're able to see hear and speak to
them all from your phone
I have ring devices all around my house
makes me feel safe makes my wife feel
safe and means that I have control of
everything happening on my property on a
constant basis as a subscriber you have
a special offer on the ring welcome kit
available right now at ring.com /ban the
kit includes a video doorbell and the
chime Pro which is just what you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home today go to ring.com slash pen
that's our ing comm slash Ben ring comm
slash Ben and you get that special offer
on a ring welcome kit will make you feel
more safe and secure makes my wife feel
more safe in skirt makes me feel more
safe and secure ring calm / man go make
your property safer okay so the
Democrats are beginning to panic and
they should be panicking because the
fact is
that Bernie Sanders is going to have
dramatic impacts down ballot
okay the the Democrats are realizing
that down ballot Bernie is a disaster
for them because Bernie is not going to
the districts that Democrats won in 2018
they are all purple districts right
these are all districts that went to
Mitt Romney in 2012 they went to
Republicans in 2014 and these are all
districts that have shifted blue
specifically out of hatred for Trump but
if Bernie's the nominee a lot of these
suburban districts are not gonna say it
stayed Democratic for very long which is
why the Washington Post is reporting the
down ballot Democrats are already moving
to distance themselves away from Sanders
according to Mike de baños and Michael
Shure over at the Washington Post
former astronaut Mark Kelly the
Democratic Party's hope for flipping a
US Senate seat in Arizona tried to do no
harm this month when he was asked about
senator Bernie Sanders he said well
ultimately support who the nominee is of
the Democratic Party that was enough for
Kelly's Republican rival senator martha
mcsalley of arizona
who's trailing him in early polls single
on the attack a television spot she
debuted days later spent nearly as much
time talking about plans by the
Democratic Socialist from Vermont to
raise taxes and award new benefits to
undocumented immigrants as it did to
Kelly as Sanders a political independent
builds what could eventually be an
insurmountable delegate lead many
Democratic House and Senate candidates
are approaching a dramatic shift in
their campaigns as they recalibrate to
include praise of capitalism and
distance themselves from the National
Party top campaign strategist from both
major parties views she enters a success
as a potentially tectonic event which
could narrow the party's already slim
hopes of retaking the Senate Majority
and fueled GOP dreams of reclaiming the
house which had lost amid a Democratic
romp in 2018 from a representative Steve
Israel Democrat of New York who is a
former longtime confidence of House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi he said I can tell
you there are a lot of down ballot
jitters based on my conversations with
my former colleagues she says Donald
Trump is gonna offer the American people
this choice do you want to continue
building the economy or do you want to
lurch toward socialism and that is a
real powerful argument in the Democratic
districts that Trump won in 2016 and
this is exactly right the bottom line is
that there are a lot of Democrats who
won in 2018 who are not aoc style
Democrats these are Democrats who won
specifically on the basis that they were
moderate and the Democratic Party then
completely ignored them and focused all
of its attention on the new rising
superstars from deep blue districts well
it turns out that was a real stupid move
because now
you're gonna end up with an actual
socialist-slash-communist a natural
Marxist at the top of your ticket and if
you are running in a purple district in
Indiana you're running in a purple
district in Ohio how you think that's
gonna go for you when every campaign ad
is you embracing the geriatric communist
so James Carville who continues to be
one of the only honest people in the
Democratic Party he says listen if you
think Sanders can win you're a sucker
because his entire basis here is that he
is going to win he's gonna run and he's
gonna win on the supposed basis that he
has a massive new turnout plan massive
new turnout plans are bound for failure
the people who show up to vote of the
people who show up to vote the question
is what you do with those people here's
Carville explaining why anybody who has
faith in Bernie Sanders this turnout
plan is fooling themselves the entire
theory that by expanding the electorate
increase in turnout you can win an
election is is the equivalent of climate
tonight all right when people say that
there is stupid to a political scientist
is is a climate denier is to an
atmospheric scientist so whatever you do
if you want to vote for Bernie Sanders
because you feel good about his program
because you don't like that the banks on
Wall Street or you don't like
pharmaceuticals that's completely
legitimate understand that if you voting
for him because you think he'll win the
election because he'll galvanise
heretofore sleepy parts of the
electorate then politically you're a
fool yeah and this is exactly right the
idea that you are going to drive out
massive new numbers of people from a
specific electorate and that's your plan
that is a failure at Barack Obama's the
only candidate in my lifetime who's been
able to do this he did it in 2012
specifically with the black community
but he had a good basis for suggesting
that he'd be able to do it cuz he did
the exact same thing in 2008 he also
happened to win among virtually all
other voters in 2008 as well so Barack
Obama won a fairly a more narrow victory
in 2012 than he did in 2008 and even he
was banking on that turnout model the
turnout model ended up being right in
some areas and wrong in other areas here
she lost votes from 2008 to 2012 from
one reelection because he'd been so
handily ahead so in Bernie who has never
come close to winning anything remotely
approaching a national election and who
is running significantly behind in
states like Wisconsin said he's gonna
turn out new groups of young voters he's
gonna have to show exactly how he's
gonna do this it's not just James
Carville james Clyburn
who is this very prominent Congress
person from South Carolina
of course he's black and he represents a
lot of black voters in South Carolina he
is coming out today and he's likely to
endorse Joe Biden that's been the
implication and he says listen Democrats
are gonna have a lot of trouble if the
Socialists at the top of the ticket
Democrats are fretting about this they
should be do believe it'll be an extra
burden for us to have to care it
this is South Carolina and South
Carolinians are pretty leery about that
title socialist and so I think that that
would be a real burden for us in these
states or congressional districts that
we have to do well then
and of course Clyburn is exactly right
this is one of the reasons why he's
probably going to endorse Biden today
meanwhile mayor Pete trying to grab that
mantle of the moderate even though he is
not moderate in any way one of his
rallies over the weekend a nine year old
boy got up and asked him about coming
out of the closet at nine cats it's a
prepubescent I mean I have serious
doubts as to whether nine year olds
really understand the full implications
of coming out as gay when they are nine
considering they have not yet had the
hormonal drive towards sex presumably
but in any case pee Buddha judge who
proclaims that he is a moderate peabody
judge he says Bernie Sanders is toxic
he's going to tear apart the party of
course this is true I believe we need to
defeat Donald Trump and turn the page on
this era in our politics by establishing
a tone of belonging bringing an end to
the vicious viciousness in the bullying
that is tearing apart our country we
must change what it feels like
that's Romero and that is a real
difference from senator Sanders
revolution with the tenor of combat and
division and polarization leading to a
future where whoever wins the day
nothing changes the toxic tone of our
politics
hey David Leonhardt at the New York
Times sort of making the same point
about Bernie Sanders today says bernie
is making a big mistake not because he's
on the left but because his entire
campaign is directed at alienating the
censer he says you have to understand
that politics is inescapably
performative voters respond to signals
they responded gestures of respect from
politicians who are willing to say in
effect we may not agree on everything
but I see you and understand what
matters to you the newly energetic
American Left says David Leonhardt a man
of the left has largely rejected this
approach choosing instead to believe a
comforting myth about swing voters being
extinct and turned out being a cure-all
it's a big mistake he says can you think
of one way that Bernie Sanders is
signaling respect to voters outside of
his base he has taken a nearly
maximalist liberal position on every
major issue
it's especially striking from him
because he has shown over his career
that he grasps the importance of
building a coalition but Sanders has
evidently decided the progressives will
no longer accept impurities or even much
tactical vagueness he along with
Elizabeth Warren has embraced policies
that are popular on the left and nowhere
else a ban on fracking the
decriminalization of border crossings
the provision of federal health benefits
to undocumented immigrants the
elimination of private health insurance
from any progressives has david lee and
hard again these are members the left
we're worrying about Bernie and they
should be each of these issues has
become a moral litmus test any
restriction of immigration is considered
a denial of human rights and he
compromised on guns or health care is an
acceptance of preventable deaths I
understand the progressive arguments on
these issues has Leonhardt but turning
every compromise into an existential
moral failing is not a smart way to
practice politics it comforts the
persuaded while anal alienating the
persuadable and this is exactly right my
bernie is alienating everybody in the
center of the country he's alienating
people who are on the borderline he's
alienating people who may not like
Trump's temperament but look at Bernie
and are frightened of Bernie if you
think that Bernie Sanders in a national
election this won't but this will be a
referendum on Trump and not on burning
I've been saying for a long time really
since 2016 who ever a presidential
election is a referendum on losses this
is true for congressional election so if
the referendum on Republican rule
Republicans do badly this is why you
know off your elections the party in
power tends to do poorly because the
party in power is the party upon whom
the
rendom is being performed well in 2020
the question that Democrats had to
decide was whether they were going to
make the election referendum on Trump or
whether they were gonna make the
referendum in the election a referendum
on somebody else in 2016 everybody
assumed that the election was going to
be a referendum on Trump it wasn't it
was it was a referendum on Hillary
Clinton and people didn't like Hillary
nobody showed up to vote for Hillary's
her Trump won in 2020 the assumption for
years has been okay now we'll get the
referendum on Trump if you run a
geriatric socialist loon bag who praises
communist dictators who suggests he
wants to remake the entire face of the
American economy who campaigns with
vicious anti-semites who do you think
the referendum is going to be on the
Democrats are making exactly the same
argument that the Jeremy Corbyn Labour
Party made in Britain that Boris Johnson
is so wild he saw out of the box and
he's so crazy that we'll have a
referendum on Boris Johnson then Boris
Johnson just stood there and pointed to
Jeremy Corbyn and one walking away
well Trump's in a very similar position
and you're seeing Democrats rightly
recognize this and begin to panic over
it some of them are whistling past the
graveyard Oh ting the obvious about
Bernie Sanders but using a bad world war
2 analogy in doing it which is
apparently very very bad we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that cars are a lot more
complicated today then when people were
growing up 40 50 years ago 40 50 years
ago could just go down to the generic
auto parts store most of the cars we're
fairly similar in make now parts are
really complicated now the cars
themselves have really high-level
technology and this means that if you
want to fix your car you probably in
many cases cannot go down to your local
auto parts store and buy what you need
and then just put it in instead you need
to order the specific correct part and
this is where the internet is fantastic
well you have a computer that means you
have access to Rock Auto comm at home
and in your pocket rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear like airlines do well I
spend up to twice as much for the exact
same parts the rockauto.com catalog it's
unique it's remarkably easy to navigate
and rockauto.com has everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's for your classic or your
daily driver get everything you need in
a few easy clicks delivered directly to
your door rockauto.com is a family
business serving Auto Parts customers
online for 20 years head on over to rock
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck right Shapiro in
there how did you hear about us pockets
they know that we sell you that helps us
it helps them as well and you're getting
the best parts at best price go check
them out right now Rock auto comm see
all the parts available right Shapiro in
there how did you hear about us box so
they know that we sent you okay so you
do have some people who are whistling
past the grave
you're saying Howard Dean for example
the former head of the DNC and nut in
his own right suggesting that he's not
worried about the down ballot effect for
Bernie Sanders which sure Howard afraid
of what it might mean for the Democratic
Party in terms of winning the White
House in November or winning down ballot
tickets if Bernie Sanders is the nominee
does that concern you not at all I'll
tell you why he certainly is a
polarizing candidate but we have an
incredibly polarizing person on the
other side Ark as I said before he
showed last night that he can energize
our core based well I mean if you can
internalize the core base well then you
would that's not how this works that's
how and you know who you'll energize the
Democratic core base George McGovern in
1972 okay so it's not enough to energize
the core base you get Dan fight for over
a pod save America those geniuses over a
pod save America here's the n54
suggesting of course Bernie can win okay
let's be real Bernie can win because any
major party candidate has about a 40
percent shot at winning in a deeply
divided country does that mean that
Bernie is likely to win on the basis of
his radicalism probably not polls also
show that Bernie Sanders is beating
Donald Trump in almost every
head-to-head matchup in his hypothetical
general election of polls so when it
tells me is that Bernie Sanders
absolutely can win this election he
comes to it with a specific set of
potential vulnerabilities primarily
around labeling a series of particularly
popular policies with an unpopular label
around democratic socialism but he can
win it because if the party unites are
on and we should also we talk all that
as weakness we talk about of strikes
okay we should talk about his strengths
okay well as we will see we're gonna get
into Bernie Sanders a little more deeply
it's amazing there is one tweet today
that just is it's an unbelievable tweet
I mean it's an incredible tweet it's a
tweet from NBC News and they tweeted if
senator Sanders wins the nomination
some Democrats worry President Trump
will hammer him on his long-buried words
in defense of governments in Nicaragua
Cuba and the USSR really are they
worried about that and question when he
say long bury words who buried those
words
members in the media who buried them
because as long as I've been
broadcasting I've been talking about
Bernie Sanders defending cuba nicaragua
in the USSR I'm among other socialist
dictatorships including Venezuela so um
who buried them and why would you expect
that people would not talk about the
fact that the Democrats are about to
nominate an out now Marxist and Chris
Matthews who's losing let's let those
Minds up in the morning come by they
should come at me no wrinkle don't even
know why I'm here anymore because I'm
trying to do is tell you guys don't
drive off the cliff like dumb and Malays
and you won't stop it you keep trying to
drop off the cliff at coming Louise is
the Democratic establishment for Trump
to Bernie I think what are you crazy why
wait why would you want Trump
why don't want Bernie instead of Trump I
mean this crazy communist what's going
on here I wonder whether the Democratic
moderates want Bernie Sanders to be
President I mean that's maybe they're
too exciting a question to raise they
don't like Trump at all do they want
Bernie Sanders to take over the
Democratic Party in perpetuity well I
mean he can't see stood over he set some
direction for the future of the party
maybe they'd rather wait for years and
put it in a Democrat that they like okay
that's not the comment that got Chris
Matthews in trouble though the crimen
that got Christmas and he's in trouble
is that he made a sort of half-assed
world war two analogy right so here's
Chris Matthews explaining that people I
started figuring out a little too late
and maybe this blitzkrieg from Bernie
Sanders is unstoppable maybe this is
like a blitz like he's not a Nazi but
it's kind of like a blitzkrieg is Chris
Matthews suggesting the people catching
I'm very late I gotta here come with a
show I was reading uh I would work to
biography last night watch Midway come
on in here and just talk I was reading
last night Brian I know you're a history
guy too
I'm reading last night about the fall of
France in the summer of 1940 and the
general renault calls up Churchill and
says it's over insurances of how can it
be you got the greatest army in Europe
how could it be over he said it's over
so I had that print suppressed feeling I
can't be as wild as Carville but he is
damn smart and I think he's damn right
on this one okay so people are going
nuts over Chris Matthews about this why
because the implication is that bernisa
not see Jesus what is wrong with you
people
seriously what's wrong with you bill
it's not what Matthews is saying
Matthews is just making a very silly
historical comparison to situations in
which people have not recognized that
something is over when it's over he's
saying Bernie
the nomination so the entire left goes
because Maddie's an anti-semite now look
at him he's an anti-semite cuz he said
first of all let me just explain
something to you you stupid ass okay let
me explain something to you if you are
deeply concerned about Chris Matthews
making a world war two analogy about
Bernie Sanders Michael Moore made one
three weeks ago in which he compared
Bernie Sanders to the French Resistance
which by implication means the rest of
the Democrats are Nazis hey second of
all if you're deeply concerned about
anti-semitism but you don't care about
the fact that Bernie Sanders is he
campaigns with open anti-semites that
Bernie Sanders is the Jeremy Corbyn of
the United States he spends all his time
hanging out with people who despise Jews
and want to see the Jewish state
destroyed
hey the Bernie Sanders over the weekend
suggested he's never spoken at an AIPAC
policy conference by the way an American
Israel Public Affairs Committee
conference he's never spoken at one not
for years ever right now when he's a
presidential candidate in 2016 never
okay he put out a statement suggesting
that he would not speak at AIPAC said
Bernie has said Bernie Sanders who again
this when people talk about his Jewish
roots he's so Jewish in terms of his
actual practice in terms of how much he
cares about Judaism not his ethnic
Judaism ethnic Judaism is ethnic Judaism
is just an ethnicity but in terms of his
actual practical Judaism and how much he
cares about Judaism dudes as Jewish as a
ham sandwich he's Jewish like Karl Marx
was Jewish okay Bernie Sanders tweets
out Israeli people have a right to live
in peace and security
so did the palace didn't give people
first of all I've not seen one shred of
evidence that Bernie actually believes
that Jewish people in Israel have a
right to live in peace and security
since he is back every single deal that
would do damage to the safety and
security of the people of Israel and
supports giving foreign aid the Hamas he
said I remain concerned about the
platform AIPAC provides for leaders who
express bigotry and the post basic
Palestinian rights for that region I
will not attend that conference as
president I will support the rights of
both Israelis and Palestinians and do
everything possible to bring peace and
security to the region bullcrap a
bullcrap AIPAC is the most milquetoast
organization in Israel affairs like the
most milto's they have everybody
Democrats Republicans moderates rat like
Dave everybody speaks to AIPAC okay but
Bernie is saying that AIPAC is too much
for him as we'll see Bernie is fine with
anti-semites in his own campaign so
spare me your crocodile Teeter is over
anti-semitism all your ridiculous left
is who don't give a damn when Jews are
under rocket
fire in Israel and don't give a damn
when shoes are being beaten on the
streets of Williamsburg now you're
coming out of the woodwork to inform me
that Chris Matthews is an anti-semite
he made an oblique statement about
people who aren't willing to accept
reality in history people are ridiculous
you're ridiculous you don't give a crap
about anti-semitism if you did wouldn't
be nominating a guy who is more than
happy to hobnob with anti-semites again
the man says Jewishness Karl Marx was
Jewish it's ridiculous
and we can get some more of Bernie than
nut in one second you guys should be
scared of nominating this nutcase but I
guess you're gonna go for it well get to
that in just one second first let's say
you have an employee let's call him I
don't know
Vishal and let's say he works in
accounting let's say works in accounting
Vishal and and let's say that Vishal is
really a great account like it really
does his job but one screw-up and he
could really screw with like all the
data in your company and what say you he
hasn't done it yet but you just want to
be sure so you put out a job listing on
zipper crews just so everybody feels a
little bit uneasy you know just so
everybody in it so Vishal knows that you
know if things go wrong then at least
there's somebody ready to replace you
would go to zip recruiter dot-com zip
recruiter com is the smartest way to
hire and now you can try zip recruiter
for free at zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire here's how zip recruiter
makes hiring faster and easier when you
post your job on zip recruiter it gets
sent out to over 100 top job sites then
zip recruiters powerful matching
technology finds people with the right
skills and experience for your job and
invites them to apply the results as you
get qualified candidates fast it's no
wonder four out of five employers who
post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the very first day go
see for yourself to try zip recruiter
for free head on over to zip recruiter
comm daily wire that a zip recruiter
comm slash a Dai ly WI re zip recruiter
comm slash at daily wire zip recruiter
is the smartest way to hire and the
smartest way to make your employees know
that they're answerable so if vishal
should screw up the accounting well at
least he knows there's somebody waiting
in the wings go check us out over at zip
recruit comm slash daily wired zip
recruiter comm slash daily wear okay so
the Democrats should be worried about
burning it should be deeply worried
about burning because burning over the
weekend he did an interview with 60
minutes and during this interview with
60 minutes he made absolutely clear that
he is in full-on
full-fledged crazy person I means a
crazy person so Bernie was asked about
Medicare for all he specifically said
over and over and over he doesn't know
how much it's gonna cost
he refuses to say much
Klaus finally he admits how much it's
gonna cost and his answer is it's gonna
cost 30 trillion dollars okay but this
doesn't bother him at all because he has
no plan to pay for it after all
communism means never having to say
you're sorry I mean really it means
never having to say how you're gonna pay
it means no like it's a feature not a
bug the fact that Bernie Sanders has no
plan is a feature it is not a bug hey
the fact that he has no plan means that
his supporters get to fill in the plan
with unicorn crap you get to scroll in
the within the colored lines with
unicorn crap that's that's the entire
plan here so here's Bernie Sanders
finally explain Medicare for all will
cost 30 trillion dollars by the way he
is going to remove you from your health
insurance but then magically he's
somehow going to be able without without
raising taxes dramatically on every
single person in the United States just
by taxing wealthy people apparently
according to Bernie Sanders he's going
to be able to pay for expanded services
and make sure you have the same doctor
and make sure you have the same care
which is patently lunacy here whenever
he cites Denmark there's some things you
should know about the Danish medical
system one the tax rates in Denmark are
insane you're paying like forty five
percent taxes if you're making above
sixty grand a year
second of all the you are able to pay
you are able to buy supplemental private
insurance in Denmark Murray's plan does
not allow for supplemental private
insurance third the services that Bernie
says he's gonna provide are bigger than
the services that Denmark provides
fourth Denmark is all run locally in
terms of its of municipal eyes health
care he won't take fully nationalized
health insurance system and Bernie's a
nutcase okay and here's Bernie going on
Medicare for all do you have a price tag
for all this we do I mean you know and
and the price tag is it will be
substantially less than letting the
current system go I think it's about
thirty trillion that's just for Medicare
for all if you have a price tag for all
of these why don't we try to no okay
well I don't I will get the pay for this
well guess who cares I'm gonna pull it
outta my ass when they fix him at the
Musil and put the money directly from is
it'll be fine
no one cares who cares if that wasn't
Bernie's biggest ridiculousness of the
night then Bernie was he asked about the
fact that he's an old communist no as I
mentioned he's not been shy about this
okay back when he was my age came back
in the 1970s he was declaring him wanted
nationalization of the banks every major
industry the energy like everything
everything he was 35 years old when he
was running
with the Liberty Union party in New
Hampshire his let's not pretend he
wasn't a 17 year old kid he wasn't the
20 euros in a 25 year old he wasn't
somebody who's getting his feet wet in
politics he was my age okay and Bernie
was doing this routine back in the 70s
he so Bernie at the time he has never
found a communist regime he can't praise
so last night
Anderson Cooper asked him about the
verboten long-buried topic according to
NBC News of the fact that he has
supported every single communist regime
he has ever come across like seriously
the man has never run across a communist
regime that can't find warm words for
it's one thing to speak at AIPAC a
milquetoast pro-israel organization that
supports the only democracy in the
Middle East that's very bad right Bernie
won't do that because Israel is well as
flower bud this world is racist but when
it comes to Cuba I will tell you Cuba
has some very good things about it so
here was Bernie on national TV last
night losing Florida we're very opposed
to the authoritarian nature of Cuba but
you know you got it's unfair to simply
say everything is bad you know when
Fidel Castro came into office you know
what he did he had a massive literacy
program is that a bad thing
even though Fidel Castro did he a lot of
dissidents in prison didn't that's right
and we condemned that and we couldn't
dump that they will read then one day I
mean tomorrow in prison should the were
in prison and sure they were reading
about how Castro was shooting the
relatives but they could read now I mean
who could complain about that they could
read every before okay a couple of
things about Bernie Sanders being a
complete and total dumb okay to a few
things one the literacy rate in Cuba was
about the same as the literacy rate in
costa rica before castro came along the
same so my best available study
somewhere between 60 and 80% of the
Cuban population could read and many
most of the studies put it like 75 76 %
that's about the same as Costa Rica you
know Costa Rica has now you know what
they had very quickly 100% literacy rate
you know Costa Rica didn't do shoot its
dissidents hey that like how many people
does Bernie think it's okay to shoot so
long as you get 100% literacy rate like
I have an easy way to establish a
hundred percent illiteracy
according to Bernie's logic in any
country you should shoot everyone who
can't read it's great 100% literacy rate
like what a complete and ridiculous
moral pathetically disgusting human
being this is it's unbelievable it's
heavenly he's literally sitting there
making me well at least move to leave me
make the trains run on time by the way
Mussolini didn't make the trains around
time Castro didn't make the country of
Cuba literate this is nuts it's not but
he did the same thing with the USSR
throughout his career bread lines are
not bad true you know they may have had
some boombox
sure there's a five-year plan where
everyone in Ukraine was killed and
people were eating each other and you
know in China during the Great Leap
Forward
when 40 million people but that was kind
of bad but let's be real about this
China has an excellent record of poverty
reduction and the USSR they have
excellent bread lines and they've
excellent cultural effects excellent we
should have exchange programs this is
who you are nominating just cuz you hate
Trump you're out of your minds you're
out of your damn minds the hell has gone
wrong with you people
seriously you hate Trump so much that
you're nominating a guy who would only
be comfortable in the car in the
confines of Karl Marx and and Frederick
angles this is who you've decided to go
with seriously this is a great way to
lose Florida by the way remember that
time when Florida was a battleground
state you know who lives in Florida a
lot of people who got on 19:7 got a 1958
Chevy's and then tried to float off an
island to a coast of another country
because they're trying to escape the
regime that bernie is praising right
here a lot of those people live in
Florida you know who else lives in
Florida a lot of elderly Jews who kind
of like Israel so well done Democrats
you basically just given away Florida
that's a genius move that's a genius
move but this is Bernie all over right
this is what bernie is bernie is a
nutcase he is a nut and you guys decided
to go all in you married the hooker guys
congratulations you couldn't have just
that one-night stand you couldn't
abandon your wife have a one-night stand
in Vegas you decided no you're gonna go
bang the hooker and then marry her so
you bought the ticket you take the ride
and don't be surprised when she cleans
out your wallet in the morning somebody
surprised when your bank accounts go on
the next day bernie is the socialist
hooker in Vegas and you married her well
done well done
I mean he's saying this stuff now he's
saying it now
I love him be like his long buried
cotton long buried communist feelings
did he ever bury them was there any
point during his career where he buried
them like any we're gonna get two more
Bernie Sanders in just a second because
it's animal it's just amazing it's just
amazing you hate Trump so much that you
think this all right
fine your choice okay we can get to more
of that in a second first gang I got to
tell you daily why our membership is the
only way you should be viewing our
content you're missing all the best
features and right now using promo code
Shapiro we get 10% off any membership
plan you choose what makes membership so
great well members get our articles at
free access to all of our live broadcast
and show library the full three hours of
the Ben Shapiro show select bonus
content access to the mailbag and more
plus our new all-access here it gets you
into exclusive live online Q&A
discussions with me Andrew Klay VIN Matt
Walsh Michael Knowles Plus daily wire
writers and special guests and don't
forget you will also get the greatest of
all beverage vessels the leftist cheers
tumbler yes you get all of that plus 10%
off when you use promo code Shapiro so
stop depriving yourself come join the
fun it's gonna be a wild year you're
listening to the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so um I think that it is worth
noting that Bernie's policies and then
his heresies are not merely confined to
his support of every horrible communist
or to my planner by way Daniel Ortega
the dictator of Nicaragua he came out
over the weekend endorse Bernie Sanders
that's an exciting endorsement that's
really good stuff but Sanders also
announced over the weekend that
undocumented immigrants illegal
immigrants to the United States are
entitled to exactly the same benefits as
citizens and he wants open borders he
says that he wants to decriminalize
border crossings and undocumented
immigrants are entitled to the same
benefits to citizens and once again I
ask you he keeps saying Denmark and
Norway is he aware of like basic
immigration law in Denmark and Norway
which are extremely restrictive it is
very difficult to become a citizen of
Denmark or Norway these are places that
have extremely restrictive immigration
policies why because there are two
things you can have but not three okay
you cannot look there's actually one
thing you can happen not to you cannot
have a vast social safety net and open
borders that those two things are
mutually exclusive unless you live in
Bernie land where you can crap rainbows
here's Bernie explaining that we should
have a completely open border and
everyone who crosses illegally should
get the exact same benefits as citizens
who live in the country and pay taxes
what our campaign is about and what our
administration will be about is
rethinking America understanding that
all of our people when I say all I also
mean be undocumented in this country
that all of our people are entitled to
basic human rights
he's just unbelievable it's it's this
this is what you've chosen okay
so Democrats naturally are turning and
they're going this is crazy this is not
but it's too late it's too late because
it turns out that you guys blew it it
turns out that you decided to feed that
alligator hoping that he would eat you
last and now you're left with dead Joe
Biden and Michael Bloomberg who better
have the debate of his life tomorrow
night or he's toast
also after blowing half a billion
dollars before a vote has been taken
with his name on the ballot so Joe Biden
after Nevada
he's been declaring a victory he's been
saying oh yeah well I came in second
isn't that great a great accomplishment
that I came in second so his record so
far is fifth fifth and second and he
believes that he is going to stage a
massive comeback in South Carolina could
happen okay realistically speaking Joe
Biden is still polling top of the heap
in South Carolina and if Joe Biden
in South Carolina it would certainly be
a shot in the arm for his campaign and
then we would find out whether Michael
Bloomberg has the actually cares about
the future of the party cuz at that
point Michael Bloomberg really should
toss all of his millions and billions
behind Biden but here's Biden saying
over the weekend we're gonna go on we're
gonna win South Carolina and then nearly
falling asleep at the podium while doing
so sure sure
hey Biden also pointed out that a
Democratic Socialist at the top a ticket
ain't gonna be a help but everybody
knows this at this point it ain't it
isn't enough to push him forward is it I
think it's gonna be very difficult for
people in purple states to have a shot
of winning look why went into 24 races
24 states and for the 2018 election and
I've campaigned for 65 candidates I
don't know that any invited Bernie could
come in campaign they all invited me to
campaign now and then we want 41 seats a
lot of those people have endorsed me in
those frontline states and I think you
have to be able to broaden the party to
be able to make sure we can keep those
folks of course he's right but not that
that matters meanwhile the problem for
Michael Bloomberg is that he can't
decide whether he wants to apologize for
being there or whether he just wants to
charge forward so Michael Bloomberg's
campaign cut a video last week it was a
video from the debate and it was a video
in which he says that he's the only
person who ran a business and then there
were all these sort of crickets as it
showed all the other candidates on stage
who had never run a business so
everybody in the media went nuts it's a
fake video a fake video
it's obviously parodic 'el you know it
wasn't in the crowd at the debate
crickets right crickets were not in the
crowd I hate to break it to you guys
crickets were not in the crowd at the
debate it was obviously a parody video
that didn't stop Bloomberg spokespeople
over the weekend from suggesting they
were out over their skis on their own
campaign videos stop apologizing if
you'd like to win the nomination perhaps
you should get your head out of your
butt and stop apologizing for your
candidate it's ridiculous Bernie Sanders
won't even apologize for having
supported communist dictatorships and
you guys are apologizing for a campaign
video that was clearly a parody
ridiculous I think all of us have to do
the right thing on social if you're
going to battle with Donald Trump you
still have to go to battle with him
honorably
we don't want to lie we don't want to
misrepresent I don't think we want to
use the kind of hateful tactics he uses
and a couple of times I think we've
gotten out over our skis
but we pull that back internally I think
for people to be creative and aggressive
they need some breathing room but we
don't want them to go too far in cases
where we have we pulled it back just
stop apologizing stop apologizing
meanwhile desperate Elizabeth Warren is
pushing on national poll today showing
that she's running second to Bernie
Sanders national polling is we have
found out with Joe Biden means
absolutely nothing it's the state
polling that means something Elizabeth
Warren is now falling into the I'm going
she's trying to be everything to
everybody so she tried to basically
draft off of Bernie Sanders right she
was driving behind him and drafting off
of him now she's trying to separate off
him and pretend that she's actually in
the moderate lane after spending a year
a campaigning as a progressive in the
race here she is yesterday explaining
she's not a Democratic Socialist after
ripping off Bernie's campaign I
appreciate the question but you got the
wrong person to ask about this I voted
for you and I appreciate that I
appreciate that but I'm not a Democratic
Socialist I believe in markets now there
are areas in any market economy there
are areas where markets don't work
education health care and we decide
collectively we're gonna manage those in
a different way and I'm all-in 100% now
she's a pretend moderate again also
Elizabeth Warren has decided that her
mean girl persona from the last debate
is going to serve her well so after she
did that crazy debate where she was just
flamed throwing everybody on stage now
she has decided that it's time to make
fun of Michael Bloomberg for being short
I'm old enough to remember when she
suggested it was bad and divisive and
choose tutting people I just tunning
Trump now she's going full Trump she's a
Michael Bloomberg is short so she's
actually picked up the mini Mike things
I want to talk specifically for just a
minute at the top about a threat that is
coming our way and it's big threat not a
tall one but a big one Michael Bloomberg
I'm old enough to remember when
Elizabeth Warren would've found this
very off-putting in fact I'm old enough
to remember last week she got a lot of
hay out of suggesting that Michael
Bloomberg was a vicious sexist because
he had said mean things about how women
look and there she's insulting his
height so obviously she has she's a
woman of high principles as Elizabeth
Warren by the way she started her own
super PAC or people around her started a
super PAC she said well us ladies are
allowed to have super PACs also so using
the genitals to defend your super PAC
and violation of promises Elizabeth
Warren
really a principled person can you see
why it is that Bernie Sanders is running
away with the nomination part of it has
to do with the insane anti Trump ISM of
the left part of it has to do with the
fact that the other Democratic
candidates are just complete and utter
ridiculous sideshows meanwhile President
Trump is is in position to win not only
reelection but to win a heavy victory I
went through the states last time in the
2016 election and we talked a little bit
about which states are up for grabs this
time around for Donald Trump and the
fact is that Trump could really
radically expand the map if he is able
to keep the economy humming so if you
look at some of the battleground states
again New Hampshire is very it was very
close in 2016 from could easily take
that yeah they're saying that the Bernie
is running ahead in Pennsylvania Trump
hasn't hit him with a single ad so far
I'm Bernie wanting to ban fracking
Wisconsin Trump is way ahead in
Wisconsin according to state polls in
Michigan bernie has not been hit with
any of his ridiculous policy suggestions
yet and it turns out that a lot of
people in Michigan kind of patriotic
also Florida was very close last time
and is not going to be close this time
if Bernie is the nominee Minnesota is up
for grabs
Nevada is certainly up for grabs Maine
is up for grabs Colorado might even be
up for grabs so we are talking about
President Trump adding maybe another 20
to 30 electoral votes Virginia might be
up for grabs because the fact is that
Bernie is so all-fired radical so you
know the Trump has the real opportunity
to expand the map now there are a couple
of obstacles to that's happening one of
course is the possibility of an economic
downturn and this is something
completely unpredictable today the Dow
opened by dropping nearly a thousand
points it drops about 900 points because
coronavirus case is outside of China
were surging according to CNBC stocks
fell sharply on Monday is the number of
coronavirus cases outside China surged
stoking fears of a prolonged global
economic slowdown from the virus
spreading the Dow Jones Industrial
Average traded 886 points lower or 3.1
percent it was travel based stocks that
were taking the hardest hit and also any
sort of company that has supply chains
in Hong Kong or China shares of casino
operators Las Vegas hands and Wynn
Resorts dropped at least 3.5 percent
each MGM slid 4.1 percent as well also
Dow components Intel traded 3.4 percent
lower it was a major
it was actually the third biggest drop
of the last three years Apple and its
suppliers took a hit as new cases are
being diagnosed because when you have
these new cases being diagnosed it may
say it means that a lot of these shops
are basically shutting down and not
reopening until coronavirus is contained
so this is very bad news for president
Trump if the economy were to tanked it
is also true that there could be a sort
of self-fulfilling prophecy here Trump
does need to stay ahead in the polls
because if Bernie were to start gaining
in the polls and start looking like a
real viable frontrunner in the actual
presidential race what you would see is
people divesting themselves of stocks
now in anticipation of Bernie Sanders
becoming president he'd start to see a
preliminary stock market drop as Bernie
Sanders got priced into the markets
there wouldn't be a precipitous drop the
day after the election and that stock
market decline in anticipation of a
possible Sanders victory could actually
doom Trump preemptively so that that's a
real problem for Trump the other problem
for President Trump is that President
Trump is now being subjected to test
case after test case of his own
inability to stop his worst instincts
from taking over what I mean by this is
that if you are a low-level staffer in
trumps administration you hate Trump and
wanna see Trump go down the easiest
thing for you to do is to put out there
a rumor that Trump doesn't like watch
him overreact and watch the story become
about the overreaction this seems to be
what has happened with regard to Joseph
Maguire so according to Ellen Nakashima
Shane Harris Josh taozi and Anne gearan
then reported back on Friday a senior US
intelligence official told lawmakers
last week that Russia wants to see
president from re-elected viewing his
administration is more favorable to the
Kremlin's interest according to people
who were briefed on the comments after
learning of that analysis analysis which
was provided to House lawmakers in a
classified hearing Trump grew angry at
his acting Director of National
Intelligence Joseph Maguire in the Oval
Office
seeing Maguire and his staff as disloyal
for speaking to Congress about Russia's
perceived preference the intelligence
officials analysis and Trump's furious
response ruined McGuire's chances of
becoming the permanent intelligence
chief so the way the media want to
unspool this story is that Maguire went
out there and rightly told Congress that
Russia wants to see Trump re-elected now
what we have heard from multiple sources
including Jake Tapper reporting it is
that what the actual underlying
intelligence shows the Russian wants to
interfere in the election but you can't
really draw a conclusion about which
candidate they're going to support I
mean honestly
why would they possibly support
President Trump who has supplied deadly
weaponry to Ukraine over Bernie's
who honeymooned in the USSR like if you
really believe that the Russians would
prefer Trump to be President / Bernard
mix Anders in actual communist a person
straight from KGB wet dreamland then I
mean but like Bernie Sanders is the plot
of no way out and you're telling me that
the Russians would like not to see him
as president of the United States like
it doesn't make any sense in fact there
was another report over the weekend that
Bernie Sanders was briefed by US
officials that Russia was trying to help
his presidential campaign which by the
way does show you that it is kind of
weird right back in 2016 there was talk
that the Russians were trying to help
the Trump campaign and Trump was never
told about it within 5 seconds of Bernie
Sanders's campaign becoming subject of
Russian interference Bernie is told
about this within five seconds which is
the way it should have worked
for the Trump campaign no okay but
president Trump's national security
adviser came out over the weekend and he
said I didn't push out my my Director of
National Intelligence chief for briefing
Congress on Russian interference or
Trump basically pushed out choice of
McGuire replacing with rook Cornell is a
good guy but the story is that Trump
wants to cover up Russian interference
in the election that benefits him and so
he fired his own intelligence chief here
as the White House national security
adviser denying this Joe McGuire wasn't
pushed out Joe McGuire's term he was in
acting he was serving into the vacancy
Act he was acting and as his term I
believe was Indian March 11th or March
12th like two weeks from now Joe had a
great relationship with the president I
had a great relationship with him we
have a lot of respect for gentleman wire
so so the premise of your question he
was pushed out it just isn't true how is
Russia interfering in the 2020 election
well there are these reports that they
they want Bernie Sanders to get elected
president that's no surprise he
honeymoon into Moscow yeah and of course
that's true
but the the fact is that what president
from should have done instead of
responding by saying Russia want Russia
when's Bernie you know I made up Bernie
instead of reacting like that he should
have said listen whoever Russia wants is
irrelevant we need to stop their
interference in the election all right
that should have been the first move and
firing the head of your office of
National Intelligence is an unforced
error
unfortunately this seems to be the
repeated sort of effect of being
battered about listen I understand why
Trump is doing it on an emotional level
I understand that Trump being attacked
by low-level people in his own
administration and then stepping in it
emotionally right this is the same thing
that happened with the Roger stone case
you had low-level DOJ officials who
without the permission of the Attorney
General went and recommended a sentence
that was way too long for Roger stone
and then William Barr stepped in and
said this is not correct and all the DOJ
officials stepped down that's fine
Trump should have kept his mouth shut
but Trump cans and so he ends up in a
position where it looks as though he's
doing things to defend his friends or
he's doing things to defend Russia that
he actually isn't doing and that leads
the Democrats to be able to tell these
stories about how Trump is screwing with
governments in order to protect himself
or no in order to protect election
corruption it leads to questions like
this here is Chuck Todd asking mark
Shore White House official about Russian
interference there has not been an
assertion that Russia is trying to
benefit Donald Trump but isn't different
than saying Donald Trump what I don't
understand is why isn't the president
concerned about Russian interference and
concerned Chuck but how about the media
covering the fact they the 2018 when
Donald Trump was president we had
midterm elections that went off without
a hitch in 2016 when there was
interference it was under the Obama
administration's regime in 2016
National Security Adviser not just about
Susan Rice told her team to stand down
okay wouldn't it oh that's true wouldn't
it have been easier for the Trump
administration to say of course we're
concerned about Russian interference
which is why we're targeting it no
matter who it helps when that should be
the easiest answer instead of letting
the emotion take control only two things
can defeat Trump in this next election
and Bernie Sanders is not one of them
one is the economy and the other is
trumpet those are the only two things
can they can defeat Trump which is why
Trump needs to control himself it's why
Trump needs to not react to even his own
staffers doing dumb things he needs to
show some element of control otherwise
it just gives the media fodder to work
with and listen they don't need help
right the media are gonna go after him
anyway but that does not mean that you
should give them the fodder with which
to work okay time for a quick thing that
I like and then a thing that I ate so
things that I like this kind of goes
under things I like and things that I
hate the reason that it goes under
things I like is because it is fun the
reason it sort of goes under things I
hate is because it does trivialize the
Holocaust so the show is hunters okay
the basic premise of the show is that
it's the aftermath of world war 2 it's
30 years later and there are still Nazis
who are living in the United States and
there's this group of elderly Jews
basically who are tracking down these
Nazis and killing them now here's the
truth you don't actually have to make
this stuff up in the aftermath of World
War two there's a great book called The
Avengers by Rick by rich Cohen then I
highly recommend it
excellent book all about how in the
aftermath of world war two there were
Jewish survivors of the Holocaust who
went through Germany tracking down old
SS members and killing them it's I mean
it's an amazing amazing story like I'd
love to see that made into a movie but
this is sort of a fantasies comic book
kind of thing it makes very clear that's
a comic book kind of thing from the very
early moments of it the the reason that
it's likable is because it's
entertaining it's definitely
entertaining the reason that it is that
it is problematic at least in my mind
and problematic according to the
Auschwitz Memorial is because instead of
just playing off of the realistic
horrors of the Holocaust it instead
creates stories about the horrors of the
Holocaust that are that are not true and
it seems to almost play up horrors that
didn't exist in contravention of horrors
that clearly did the sort of generic
horror of the Holocaust in order to tell
stories about Nazis being even more evil
than they actually were which is
something you don't need to do in any
case it's it's certainly good
entertainment the only question is
whether it it does a disservice in the
same way that if you made a movie about
slavery and the movie was about people
doing things to slaves that actually
weren't realistic and so it ends up
being in sort of a trivialization of the
actual evils of slavery sort of the same
thing here but is it worth the watch
it's probably worth the watch there's a
little bit of the preview for hunters
what do you say agent Morris I think
there's Nazis living in America and
someone out there is taken enough
just to see there is a right way and a
wrong way to get justice
okay so the entire thing is supposed to
also be a meditation on revenge and the
evils of revenge or the good of revenge
and all of the all this sort of stuff
but the fact is it's the cartoon enos of
the the cartoon eNOS of this that is
that it's kind of you know it is both
the appeal of the show it is also the
downfall of the show does also the
drawback of the show also it goes along
with this ridiculous plot that Nazis are
gonna retake the American government and
it's got this sort of intersectional
logic to it where it's all of the
intersectional small groups fighting
against this evil white superstructure
that isn't increasingly dominated by
Nazis you know all of that has to be
taken into account okay time for a quick
thing that I hate okay so a quick thing
that I hate Tom Nichols is a guy who
considers himself a sort of never Trump
expert he wrote a book called the death
of expertise about why people are not
taking experts seriously I just have to
point out that this is one of the
dumbest tweets I've ever seen so Tom
Nichols tweeted out over the weekend
Rhode Island's primary isn't until late
so I get to register as a Democrat to
cast a protest vote in the primary
against Sanders as the inevitable
nominee I will then vote for as a
protest against the incumbent good job
everyone good job everyone
I mean aren't you an independent human
being who gets to make your own
decisions here and why would you cast a
vote you're never Trumper so you really
hate Trump so much do you think that
Bernie Sanders an overt communist and by
the way a corrupt / a communist because
his wife was getting contracts on
particular government boards while he
was in like people have not examined
Jane Sanders is rather interesting
financial history he's gonna vote for
Bernie as a protest against Trump and
then call himself the savior of
republicanism and conservatism like this
is where people are off the train with
the so called never drummers okay so
back in 2016 I was a quote never Trump
er meaning I didn't vote for Trump in
the primary I didn't vote for Trump in
the general election and I said neither
of these candidates meets my minimum for
being president of the United States
after the election I became what I've
called a sometimes Trumper meaning when
he does good things that's right and
when he does bad things that's bad and
now when I look at an election between
Donald Trump a man who has done many
many good things in terms of policy a
man who has the same character flaws
that I thought he had back in 2016 a man
who says things that I find sometimes
fantastic and sometimes reprehensible
and then I look at that compared to a
person who represents the worst ideology
of the last 150 years that's not a
particularly hard call it is not I'm
sorry that is not Sanders versus Trump
is not a hard call if you're protesting
Donald Trump and his supposed venal T's
and you're protesting Donald Trump and
his excesses and his problems of
temperament by voting for Bernie Sanders
in a general election let me suggest you
leave screwed-up morality so badly you
have no credibility to speak about
conservatism or virtually anything else
in the future when it comes to politics
the expertise expertise just
unbelievable ridiculousness okay we will
be back here later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise we
will be back here tomorrow for much much
more as we prepare for the next Rock'em
Sock'em round of democratic debates if
the democrats by the way don't figure
this thing out and start attacking
Bernie Sanders on the stage right it's
got to be all in on Bernie right I mean
if they'd go after Bloomberg again it
just demonstrates how insane they all
are in the lead-up to South Carolina but
I'm sure we will find out in short order
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]